is this just the business cycle SP goes
up people pay more for paintings no this
is an exquisite extraordinary painting
this is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
to acquire one of the best Picasso
paintings remaining in private hands I'm
hearing you but nobody at this table is
gonna be bidding on that painting what
we're trying to understand is generally
prices are going up not just for this
exquisite work generally prices are
going up but also for the best of the
best
what we're seeing in the art market is
an incredible flight to quality where
people are ready to pay unprecedented
prices over and over again for
masterpieces so that's how you define
quality Picasso there is an appreciation
for well known brand names and Picasso
exemplifies that but the best example is
by any artist or what's best appreciate
you made this in 1954-55 off the
Delacroix classic and we're on Bloomberg
radio right now I'm not going to explain
the painting but I am going to explain
the strange word that Christie's uses
modern is this a modern auction or all
the hipsters the hedge fund crew are
they all you know they're gonna be you
know you're going after Monet or Matisse
or whoever next it's a little bit of
both it's a concept sale and this is a
one-off sale that we're doing titled
looking forward to the past excuse me a
concept sale is private school for your
kids that's a concept okay thank you we
are instead of selling works only in our
traditional categories this season which
are Impressionists in modern and whose
more in contemporary we decided to
curate a sale that is targeted to what
we think most collectors are looking for
right now which is great examples from
the 20th century so the sale will be
spanning works from Monet to john curran
Picabia
to Kippenberger let's look at the return
on this sale was last sold in 1997 for
31 million dollars we're now looking at
a hundred and forty million dollars what
has changed in the collecting world that
makes that kind of appreciation possible
well overall and that's changes in the
economy but also it's the rarity of this
piece has changed over that period of
time and there are other indicators so
another work that was sold in the same
sale in 1997 Loras for 48 million
dollars which famously resold privately
not that long ago for 159 okay within
this and you mentioned this before that
auctions are about death they're about
debt and that what was the other divorce
divorce as well who is this painting now
and why are they selling it it's coming
from a private collection and no and she
got it for close to two decades and so
you know in our world that isn't isn't
much of a trader mentality they're they
really collected and love to piss paint
like sitting over a couch
yeah toms know but I put my elbow
through it if I somebody's remodeling
she no longer fits with the color
palette in the know but seriously we
really doesn't have everything in common
with Laura's and so that story is
excluded but it was in a personal
collection and now we don't know go to a
personal or Institute thank you so much